if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others
you need to understand your values
that's why the minimalist created a free
downloadable and printable values
worksheet
that will help you identify all of your
different values
and the obstacles that are in your way
head on over to theminimalists.com
v to download your free values worksheet
today
enjoy minimalists
what are some good ways to check in on
an introvert during difficult times
without overwhelming them so
josh this question is for you i don't
yeah i mean i'm the biggest introvert i
know i i spend i have a wife and a
daughter i've spent
70 plus percent of my time alone um
well some introverts don't like they
need help but they won't ask for it i
don't think you're that type of person
but i think that i do
i do struggle with it though yeah a
little bit so yeah i do see where this
question is coming from but i literally
like josh has called me before
and he's like hey man uh i'm having a
rough time um
you're not gonna hear from me for a week
and don't call me and i'm like okay
yeah if you need that time man like
that's that's the key though man
you just hit the nail on the head it's
being understanding of the person where
they are right
what does compassion mean right it comes
from from two words the
the the latin come come
is that latin i didn't know i spoke
which ironically means to be in is
better miscovered in latin
a latin bedsheet
and then pass us which means it's the
same root as passion which means to
suffer
so compassion just means to be in
suffering this with someone
and so like if if you if you're trying
to be compassionate towards someone
it's understanding they're suffering
where they are you don't by the way this
is where i fail all the time
i don't know if you experience this all
but i always try to solve the problem
yeah yeah i'm like oh wife comes to me
look i'm i
i just uncovered some trauma here's what
you should do well great i've got the
three-step
solution to fix this yeah and i've
learned over the last
year or two specifically to really just
step back and listen
and that's the compassion yeah and you
don't have to feel the suffering with
them that that's empathy right the the
feeling whatever someone else feels but
being
in the suffering with them is
is quite often all you need to do bear
witness i
it took me the first couple years of the
marriage
until she finally said i don't need you
to solve this i need you to listen
and i was like well that's against my
instinct
here's you here's why you need that the
reason why you don't want me to solve
your problems is because
yeah it was i was always in solution
mode
yes would you saw it as binary it's like
if you you saw as like the
the handyman coming to to fig or the
plumber's showing up to fix the faucet
right why would you tell me there's a
problem if you don't want me to fix it
exactly yeah
where it's like what there is a problem
but the solution is you listening yes
oh yeah and man that's it's still hard
for me now
it's like you call the plumber and he
shows up with a chainsaw see there's a
30s for a chance
well i think it's not intuitive to us
because it's like calling the plumber
and he shows up to just listen that
there's a
a pipe leaking and then he leaves and
you pay him 60 bucks
wait a minute wait a second yeah that is
a leaky pipe
your instinct was right
[Laughter]
so yeah i mean i think i think that is
the key and by the way we're all
hypocrites
understanding that as well um wrote this
this essay recently uh over on our
website it's called
compassion for hypocrites but um
the the i think the first line of is it
is the man who
protests capitalism using a chains or
using
i've got chainsaws like oh my man
the man who protests capitalism using
the megaphone he purchased from walmart
and and i think there are a bunch of
other examples there like the vegan who
who sprays we're all hypocrites garden
right
all of us are good yeah and instead of
the final one was like the minimalist
who owns six jackets that's me
right and and like so like i realized
that i live in l.a man
sometimes you're in boyle heights there
are six seasons here in los angeles
you might be in lowe's feliz it might
might be change it down to 62 degrees
instead of 67.
yeah do you have a jacket for every
eight degrees yeah it's perfect
by the way like i've never needed a
jacket here either but that's my point
i'm i'm a hypocrite like have compassion
for me and i'll i'll do my best to have
compassion
for for other people as well and some
people like
that that was a really popular thing and
it spread but some people really
misunderstood it
like oh yeah they were all the comments
they were like yeah yeah
look look at yeah yeah but uh here's
some here's a list of some other
hypocrites i'm like
no no no you didn't read the rest of the
thing it was about why i didn't have
compassion
for other people why it's necessary to
bear witness
uh because we're all a little bit [ __ ]
up well when we judge hypocrites it's
because we're looking at that person and
we think to ourselves we can never be a
hypocrite like that
so we project this judgment that really
we're putting on ourselves
but if we took a second to stop and look
we could realize like oh like we are
hypocrites in our own way
so and i'm easy on myself with like i
use an apple computer
i mean if i really think about it i feel
like a piece of [ __ ] for using an apple
computer with
the damage does the environment the the
factories over in china
it's like uh but i can get through it
and i can be like all right ryan you're
not a piece of [ __ ] for using an apple
computer
um so yeah so much better than pc you're
like so [ __ ] right exactly
i would use people you know what factory
schmacktory this
factory is in my backpack
is the person tweeting about income
inequality on a device that was made by
underpaid workers right
right yeah a hundred it's one of the big
problems some people have
with which i don't with nba players
right now
not speaking out against china because
china is such a big
purchaser of the nba in the nba yeah and
the nba gets so much money and if we're
talking about
people's rights yes who's
you know it doesn't get much more
egregious than what happens over in
china yeah
so i know some people like so some
people consider that to be but i
here's kind of where i fall in the
hypocrite thing
look you're always more interested in
what's happening in your house than
somebody else's
so i'm gonna care more about what's
happening here that what about the
women's rights in saudi arabia yeah
unfortunately i don't live there so it
doesn't
if i'm being honest with you we didn't
evolve to care about it yeah it doesn't
resonate you don't have the capacity to
care for every single problem yeah it
doesn't resonate it doesn't resonate
with it
can you wait one second i have to
there's a dude i'm supposed to hop on a
zoom with it one
i just want to tell him it's gonna be
130. well yeah yeah all right cool hold
on one second let's go
cool well i'll just keep talking real
quick um so
let me get back to peter's question here
as an introvert
let me oh yeah let me just say this how
do you want to be approached josh
yeah i i as an introvert that's the
irony is like i don't
usually want to be approached but what
if you really need help though and like
you're struggling asking for help
right but i think it's up to me to
determine whether or not i need help
right yeah here's the problem so maybe
that's the way to approach it hey
uh i see you're going through a rough
time can i help yeah i think that's a
bad
a bad way to approach it actually i
don't think i don't think ever asking
someone
how can i help is useful um i think
maybe
i shouldn't say ever that's wrong but i
think quite often
um it's best to if you really want to
help someone
yeah know who they are and what they
need and just
try to help in that way instead of
asking how you can help
um now how do you get to know who they
are um
you spend time with them you have these
these discussions you identify what your
values are
and if you do that then if someone needs
help
you can say hey i'll listen uh i'm here
to listen so maybe yeah so maybe it's
opening up an opportunity to listen yeah
yeah instead of flat out saying how can
i help
yeah listening to the person then maybe
they might
you know signal a way for you to help
just listening to them or maybe that's
all they need
you